hi everyone my name is Dylan I'm an
algorithm developer at trickle and I'm
really excited to be here I want to tell
you today about a project that I've been
working on which actually started on my
first day at wiggle when I came to my
boss and I asked what am I going to be
working on and I thought he was just
going to give me a small irrelevant task
and he said well you have to create
knowledge of all the product types in
the world and I was thinking okay that
doesn't sound small and it really isn't
and so after a while I'm here to tell
you about trigger and about my project
so our our mission into a goal is to
connect shoppers to the product they
want to buy through a technology that
understands them we have a few products
at wiggle we have a search enhancement
product we have catalog enriched with
product and we also have a super cool
voice app so you can imagine going
around your house saying oh no I forgot
to buy milk and it will be your phone
will reply edit your favorite kind of
milk to the cart
what so I think that's pretty cool and
forward and what's common to all these
products is that they all require two
things they require natural language
analyzer which understand the different
parts of the language and I will not be
talking about that part today but the
second thing that we need is knowledge
which is represented as the universal
product ontology now if you don't
understand what I mean by knowledge or
ontology that's okay cuz I'm going to
explain that right now so our
intelligent wigle includes a few things
the first one is the knowledge of
product types and what I mean by that if
you have two products then if they are
interchangeable then it means they
belong to the same product type let me
give an example let's say I go to the
supermarket and I want to buy Dijon
mustard but they just ran out of it so I
might be disappointed but I guess I'll
just go ahead and buy your American
mustard instead so that means that they
both belong to the same product type
they're both mustard now what's a little
bit more complex is that they
different product types can help
relations between them so our mustard
can have a certain relationship with the
mustard spice as humans it's kind of
intuitive to us to think well they
probably share the same main ingredient
they might have a similar flavor and on
the other hand the mustard can have some
kind of other relationship with the
ketchup they're both condiments they can
be used for the same purpose mainly so
they have that relationship and they
have a whole other relationship with a
mustard spice so this is where it gets a
little bit tricky and for us again as
humans it's pretty intuitive but for a
computer it's going to be much more
complicated the third part is properties
so my mustard can have can come in
different packages can come in a jar and
come in a bottle can have different
sizes can come from different brands and
the fourth part which is also a little
bit tricky is constraints because if I
have a yellow mustard and I have a brown
mustard then you might be able to think
okay let's combine the knowledge of
color with the knowledge of mustard but
actually we cannot do that because there
is no such thing as the green mustard or
a blue mustard so we have to constrain
that in a way and we also have to know
that a yellow mustard is exactly the
same thing as an American master and
well I just spent the last few minutes
talking about mustard but there are
thousands of other product types in the
world and each one of them has just as
many properties and constraints and
relations with other product types so by
now you're probably thinking okay this
might be complicated and this is where I
come in
well my goal in a project is to automate
the process of knowledge generation and
I'm going to be doing that by following
users logic all right I want to create
knowledge in the way people actually
searching for
so if tomato is actually a fruit I might
not want to create that kind of
knowledge because people don't search
that way and another important thing is
that I want to keep human in the loop we
have a very intelligent very talented
domain experts in Twitter and I want to
keep them in the process because I don't
think
I can reach their level of understanding
and their level of building the
knowledge that's why I want to create
suggestions for product types based on
user data and I want to give these
suggestions to our domain experts in
Twitter and the last assumption the last
guideline which I'm going to go back to
it later is that it's going to be easier
for a person to split prototype than to
join them
so if our domain experts have to look at
all the different product types and then
think maybe this is like this maybe I
should connect them it's going to take
them longer than just looking at a
single product type and maybe need to
split it and I will go back to it
alright so how how are we going to do it
how are we going to create that kind of
knowledge it's complicated
so I have four main steps in my
algorithm the first one will be to
create a graph containing many many
products then I'm going to embed the
graphs I'm going to assign every node a
vector and I'm going to cluster it and
give it a name every cluster so you can
think of a huge huge graph containing
probably hopefully all the different
products in the world and then I just
want to split that graph into the
different product types I want to say
this part of the graph is a cucumber
this part of the graph is a tomato and
hopefully it will work
alright so let's dive into each one of
these steps alright so like all your
things in life my algorithm starts with
a graph and the first information that
and my graph has nodes which are queries
and products and it also has edges
connecting them and the first piece of
information which I'm putting in the
graph is real users click and so if
someone looked for feta and it clicked
on the product then I'm making that
connection and here the thickness of the
line indicates the number of people that
have made this click alright so if the
line is think it means that many many
people clicked on the product after
searching that query
right the second piece of information
that are putting in my graph is results
from search engines so in Twitter we
created automatically many many queries
that went to search engines and we saw
what product we're getting in return so
I'm also putting that in the graph
I'm also connecting products which are
in the same category in the website and
I'm going to connect queries based on
external authorities so if I have an
external Authority which told me that
feta and Brie are both types of [ __ ]
then I'm making this connection and at
this point you might ask yourself well
if you have an external Authority why
are you putting that much effort into
creating your own and the answer is that
it's just not fitting to our need so for
example an external authority will tell
me that tomato with the fruit but I
don't want that kind of knowledge and at
this point to my ask yourself another
question if I'm building the graph this
way then how am I getting a one big rest
containing all the products rather than
many many many small graphs each one of
a product type because you wouldn't
expect there to be a connection between
the graph between cheese and the garbage
bag right so the answer isn't I bet you
guys will all know what I mean data is
messy so in users click sometimes people
click not on the product they search for
please don't do that
and also products are in the same
category can also be kind of confusing
because we can have categories like sale
or Christmas that will contain many
types of products yeah but it's good
this is where it gets interesting
all right so actually it looks something
something like this this is just a small
small piece of my graph and again I'm
building a huge graph of product and I
want to divide them into the different
product types now if you want to perform
a clustering algorithm to on on this
graph then I need vectors I don't need
nodes I don't need a graph I need
vectors this is why I need to embed the
graph
and make every know the vector and this
is where I'm using note to back this is
a good time to pause and say yeah thank
you for their meetups because about a
year ago my colleague was here in a
meet-up and he heard about no to back
and this is how we got the inspiration
for our project so thank you or meetups
and good things can come out of it and
back to our and thank Kelly or of course
for his lecture and back to our to our
algorithm so I want to embed the graph
and turn every node into a vector I'm
going to be doing it with no to back and
the way no to backwards is kind of cool
it is based on word embeddings so in
water bindings we're turning every word
into a vector and our input is many many
many sentences of the language so when
I'm doing it for the graphs I have nodes
and I want to turn them in so vector and
so my input is going to be walks into
graphs okay so if in the language
sentence is a sequence of words then in
a graph walk is a sequence of nodes as
you can see here now since I'm not going
to be sampling all the works in the
graph because you've seen how big the
graph is I'm going to sample the walks
and so the way I sample the walks is
crucial for the output of the algorithm
and I can sample the walks in a more
outgoing way or more localized the way a
BFS versus DFS can and it can be
controlled with two parameters P and Q I
can also control the number of
dimensions I have the length of every
walk and the number of walks I takes
from every point and we actually tune
these parameters using a small tag set
alright so once we've done that we had a
graph now it's gone we have a bunch of
vectors we can cluster them that's great
and I use the DB scan algorithm I used
it because it doesn't require prior
knowledge of the number of clusters
because I don't know how many product
lies I'm going to get and what it does
require is two parameters the maximal
distance between two points in order for
them to be in
in cluster and the minimum number of
points per cluster to be considered a
cluster and all the points which do not
answer these criteria are just being
classified as outliers all right so I
got my question and now I'm going to go
ahead and give each cluster your name
I'm going to be doing that by choosing
the most frequent and RAM out of all of
the titles of the products and the
queries in a product type you know in a
cluster and the rest of the engrams will
be used as seen as suggestions for
synonyms and my last step is going to be
to connect product type to connect them
clusters and so I which I've giving them
the same name why am i doing that as
I've mentioned before it's going to be
harder for a person to join clusters so
I want the algorithm to try and do it
instead if I have clusters which need to
be grouped together let's give that to
the algorithm rather than the person
alright so hopefully by that point I got
my clusters which are the product types
and each one of them will contain
products query the name and the
suggestions for synonyms I think it's
time we see some examples so I ran the
algorithm on the furniture domain and I
got many many many product types as you
can see if you would have to think of
all the different types of furniture you
have in your home I'm sure you wouldn't
have gotten to that list and there are
things in here which I didn't even know
existed but our domain expert state make
this so why believe them and what's cool
is that we were able to capture a lot of
synonyms so for example the product side
table can be called in many different
names like accent table sofa table
pedestal table I don't know and if a
person had to go and look for all these
steel names then probably would have
taken a long time but here we just got
it like that from the clustering so
that's kind of cool
we also ran the algorithm on the fashion
domain and again many product types I
wouldn't have thought of them in like a
million years and we actually found that
the
cheering helps us to solve problems of
disambiguation so for example the
product on your right has many product
types in its name so it would be hard to
tell what it is exactly you can see from
the picture of it and so here we know
it's a slipper because it got clustered
together with the rest of the Snickers
cool and also the naming algorithm
turned out to be pretty useful as well
you can see here many products and they
have different kind of name and the
algorithm decided to call them all face
wash which I think it's a it's a good
name for it and yeah so we were able to
create knowledge at scale we took tens
of thousands of products and we grouped
them into different product types and we
were able to do it with I think we're
more than distant percentage of accuracy
so for example in the fashion domain we
took 60,000 products and we grouped them
to 65 product types so it's roughly a
thousand products per product type and
out of these thousand products eighty
percent really belong there and I think
it's a rather big test that were able to
accomplish and hopefully I've managed to
convince you that creating knowledge is
the hard task and this is exactly what
we do at Regal where we combine complex
algorithms with human insight and I hope
you enjoy the talk and if you have any
question and we happy to answer
sorry big imbalance of words towards and
the data will our data was queries and
products so we had we didn't know what
are the types of the product we had to
create that that understanding yeah same
balance and right so that's a great
question the question was how do we deal
with the
understanding of attributes because I
mainly spoke about understanding product
types and attributes is actually a very
hard task so well we have a few ways of
dealing with dealing with it we're
currently building um an automatic flow
to deal with it but the it's it's hard
right that's a great question how will I
deal with the new products so the answer
is that whenever I get a new set of data
which contains maybe more products more
queries and more categories whatever I
can always just insert that to my graph
and and just do the whole algorithm or
what's more yeah yeah well it just dal
going just takes you know like a few
minutes to to run so I can whenever I
need I can just do it again and find
more product types given any new
information that I received it takes a
few minutes because I'm separating the
data two domains but even if I wouldn't
have done it it would just take you know
maximum an hour or something you're
right i right yeah I forgot to say it so
thank you for asking for the clustering
algorithm the DB scan i also tuned the
parameters with with a small tag set but
we also kept like checking the sanity of
the parameters it's very crucial when
for example when we looked at the
minimum points which need to be
clustered together to be considered a
group the minimum points per group then
we thought about how many catalogs we
have
how many products we would expect for a
product like to be in the catalog I mean
I would expect ok there will be one
tomato in every catalog so this is the
minimum number of points that I need per
cluster so we kept connecting it to the
real problem yes so ok
well I saw that in my in my graph the
the weight of the edges is taken from
the number of clicks and actually the
rest of the data which I'm inserting is
getting a rather low weight because I
want to keep I want to make the users
data as much important as it can be
because it's the most crucial part of
their data and once I'm putting the
weights inside the graph then no tuvok's
takes that into consideration and the
embedding is done accordingly because
the weight of the edges is very
important for the embedding of the graph
yes ok so given a new product that we
have how is it affecting the algorithm
yeah so it really depends on how many
new products I'm putting in the graph
because it contains the you know
hundreds of thousands of nodes so
probably one or two products will not be
much of a difference
but if I'm putting inside if I'm putting
a new source of information it has a lot
of many new products and prototypes then
it can change of course the result but
we always we check what it doesn't need
to be changed
be different are we putting a new
product types are we expecting it to be
any different so yeah the more data we
have it's better right so we have a
random walk and you're asking how how
sensitive so I think it really depends
okay the amount like how would I say the
change in the categories when we take
different sampling of the graph is
depends very much on where you look in
the graph because some some parts of the
graphs are more in the graph or a more
dense yes thank you
are more dense and so it will affect
them a little bit less and there are
some parts of the graph where we have
maybe little information a little bit
data so they are very they're very
sensitive to to changing in parameters
and and these are the parts that we
always try to to improve to putting more
data to make it more robust and to
improve all the parts that are there are
not that tenses others yep all right
thank you everyone
[Applause]